what is very important yes I only do
this I do this and I shower and brush my
teeth this it's gratitude and
I'm here because I know your inspiration
for all of the fans around the world
your inspiration is very good for us but
sometimes it's very hard of course but
that's part of being a human being
sometimes it's hard for a day sometimes
it's hard for a week sometimes it's hard
for a month sometimes it's hard for a
year sometimes it's hard for a decade
there's people who have substance abuse
issues for 10 years and they get out of
it when it's hard that's when you have
to go to gratitude when it's hard you
say at least my mother's alive or even
if your mother's not alive at least I
had a great mother for 20 years or look
at this daughter I have or the Sun is up
and I have a chance to make it better
today you have to lean to gratitude this
is perfect that I wore this shirt today
this is it this is the answer to heart
to be grateful for what you have instead
of what's not working
thank you you're welcome brother